erwacht aus dem koma der vergiftete
kreml-kritiker navalny ist nach angaben
der berliner charité wieder ansprechbar
300 euro für jedes kind mit der
auszahlung des kinderbonus will die
bundesregierung familien in der korona
krise unterstützen und disqualifikation
für djokovic bei den us open schlägt der
top-favorit wütend einen ball weg und
trifft eine linienrichterin
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber und der sagt guten
abend in allen willkommen bei uns heute
um 7 sport nachher in der sendung mit
kristin otto die behandelnden ärzte in
berlin haben den russischen
kremlkritiker alexej nawalny aus dem
künstlichen koma geholt er sei jetzt
ansprechbar
navalny liegt in der charité in berlin
nachdem er auf einem flug in russland
mit vergiftungserscheinungen
zusammengebrochen war
analysen eines bundeswehr labors hatten
ergeben dass navalny mit dem
militärischen nervengift naujok
vergiftet wurde
ob der fall jetzt auch auswirkungen hat
für die zukunft des deutsch russischen
erdgas projekt nord stream 2 ist in der
diskussion patricia wiedemeier seit dem
august wird alexei navalny hier in der
berliner charité behandelt heute
nachmittag dann die nachricht sein
zustand hat sich verbessert
in einer kurzen pressemitteilung wie es
die charité verlauten dass durch
medikamente aufrechterhaltene künstliche
koma des patienten konnte beendet werden
der patient wird schrittweise von der
maschinelle beatmung entwöhnt er
reagiert auf ansprache wer für den
giftanschlag auf navalny verantwortlich
ist bleibt umstritten
in berlin weist für viele die
indizienkette nach russland der sprecher
von vladimir putin jedoch weist heute
alle schuldzuweisungen zurück versuche
russland irgendwie damit in verbindung
zu bringen sind für uns inakzeptabel
sie sind absurd und auch die diskussion
um mögliche sanktionen um ein ende der
umstrittenen ostseepipeline nord stream
2 geht weiter die grünen fordern das aus
für die pipeline nicht nur aus
politischen gründen
diese pipeline spaltet europa sie ist
ökologisch unsinnig und
überdimensioniert und sie ist
sicherheitspolitisch falsch und selbst
die bundeskanzlerin die bisher festhielt
an dem projekt schließt jetzt ähnlich
wie außenminister maß konsequenzen nicht
mehr aus so ihr regierungssprecher
ja die bundeskanzlerin sieht es auch so
dass es falsch ist etwas auszuschließen
auch wenn es heute positive nachrichten
aus der charité gab die deutsch
russischen beziehungen sind und bleibt
angespannt bringen unsere komponenten
wird dazu in berlin und in moskau
theo koll zur nächsten nach berlin den
druck auf moskau wolle man erhöhen sagt
die bundesregierung wie sehr erhöht sie
denn tatsächlich diesen druck ja erst
einmal erhöht die bundesregierung vor
allem den druck auf sich selbst in die
worte werden immer schärfer und am ende
müssten dann ja auch taten folgen sonst
droht berlin politischer gesichtsverlust
bisher war merkels linie die pipeline
klar von anderen politischen fragen zu
trennen
das ist seit heute vorbei in
hintergrundgesprächen wird hier in
berlin klar gemacht dass die
bundesregierung jetzt deutlich bereit
ist sich den neuen außenpolitischen
wirklichkeiten zu stellen sowohl gegen
ein ja jegliche grenzen austesten des
russland als auch gegen das immer
aggressiver auftretenden china im
übrigen wird hier hinter den kulissen
sehr klar gemacht dass der nato alle
erkenntnisse über das bei einer wahlen
die festgestellte gift übermittelt
wurden und dass damit auch die us
regierung diese ergebnisse hat anders
als von donald trump behauptet und dann
die frage nach moskau genannt filme wie
wichtig ist denn dieses nord stream zwei
projekt für russland der bau der
pipeline war wichtig für russland denn
daran haben enge vertraute von präsident
putin mitverdient geopolitisch ist die
pipeline auch wichtig für russland denn
sollte sie einmal stehen dann wäre es
moskau möglich den gas transit durch die
ukraine zu stoppen russland bezeugt wird
heuer zwar immer das ist das nicht
vorhabe aber es würde eben doch eine art
druckmittel gegen kiew sein man könnte
der ukraine wichtige einnahmen aus dem
gas transit verwehren fernseher gesehen
ist die gaspipeline nord stream zwei
vielleicht etwas weniger bedeutend als
man auf den ersten blick denken könnte
denn auf der einen seite ist der
russische staatshaushalt stark
angewiesen auf die exporte von
rohstoffen aber in dieser rechnung nimmt
gazprom einen kleineren teil 1 als
andere staatskonzerne wie zum beispiel
rosneft herzlichen dank
und theo die entwicklung in belarus
bietet weiter anlass zu großer sorge die
staatsführung in minsk geht weiter hart
gegen die demokratiebewegung vor von
einer ihrer anführer rinnen der 38 jahre
alten maria kohl s nico war fehlt
aktuell jede spur
auch zwei mitarbeiter von ihr sind
verschwunden ob sie verhaftet wurden
oder was mit ihnen geschah unklar
christiansen berichtet das soll der
moment sein in dem maria kohl es nie
koffer verschwindet heute morgen um 10
mitten in minsk verschleppt in diesem
schwarzen transporter bislang fehlt jede
spur von der beliebten
oppositionspolitikerin man zerschlägt
den koordinierungsrat in einzelne teile
um die menschen auseinander zu bringen
und chaos zu schaffen und um dann die
macht in einer hand zu halten
es werden menschen entführt und sie
verschwinden und keiner haftet dafür
gestern noch war maria kulissen die
koffer inmitten der demonstranten bei
den protesten gegen präsident
lukaschenko unterwegs zehntausende waren
wieder auf die straße gegangen
laut innenministerium gab es über 600
festnahm
auch wild prügelnde sicherheitskräfte
und vermummte machten jagd auf
demonstranten
maria kohl s nikkor wusste dass sie in
gefahr ist sie war die letzte führende
frau der opposition die noch in belarus
war das frauen trio das in den
vergangenen wochen den kampf mit
präsident lukaschenko aufgenommen hatte
wurde nach und nach auseinandergerissen
präsidentschaftskandidatin tieren of
skye musste nach massivem druck nach
litauen flüchten
auch veronika zepp carlo ging ins
ausland und jetzt ist maria kohlessen
koffer spurlos verschwunden
svetlana tier allofs klar macht dass
lukaschenko system dafür verantwortlich
die behörden sind in terror verwickelt
ich kann kein anderes wort finden um
dies zu beschreiben schreibt sie auf
ihrem social media kanal die polizei in
mainz gesagt sie habe kolesnikova nicht
festgenommen
und auch aus dem innenministerium heißt
es man habe keine informationen
unser nächstes thema und damit nach
deutschland und zur frage ein tropfen
auf den heißen stein oder eine wichtige
maßnahme die hilfe
wo es am nötigsten ist ab heute gibt es
300 euro kinderbonus vom staat als
unterstützung für familien in der korona
krise und zwar in zwei raten pro kind
erstmal 200 und dann im oktober noch
einmal 100 euro zusätzlich zum
kindergeld überwiesen wird das
automatisch und zwar für alle die in
diesem jahr mindestens einen monat
anspruch auf kindergeld haben allerdings
das ganze verrechnet der staat mit dem
kinderfreibetrag und das heißt
beispielsweise eine familie mit einem
kind hat ab einem jährlichen
gesamteinkommen von knapp 86.000 euro
nichts davon wenn glas schulen und kitas
über viele wochen geschlossen kinder die
zu hause betreut und versorgt werden
mussten
daniela hettich hat das als mutter
miterlebt aber auch bei ihrer arbeit als
erzieherin
es sind belastende monate die viele
familien hinter sich haben psychisch und
häufig auch finanziell
der sogenannte kinderbonus soll die
belastungen nun zumindest abfedern
ich krieg mit dass es viele familien
gibt die das wirklich brauchen weil sie
jetzt in der zeit wo die kinder zu hause
waren viel höhere kosten hatten und es
bei denen schon ein riesen loch in die
haushaltskasse gerissen hat zusätzlich
zu einer eventuellen gehaltskürzungen
durch kurzarbeitergeld nun gibt es also
300 euro zusätzlich pro kind der
kinderbonus ist ein teil des
konjunkturpakets der bundesregierung 4,3
milliarden euro wird er kosten und soll
auch helfen die konjunktur anzuschieben
das hat einen kleinen effekt allenfalls
auf die konjunktur dh es wird vermutlich
nicht so viel bringen
aber andererseits wenn man die sozial
politische ausgewogenheit des
konjunkturpaketes anschaut dann war es
sicher auch sinnvoll ein solches element
mit aufzunehmen
denn profitieren werden vor allem
familien mit mittleren und geringeren
einkommen ihnen bleibt der kinderbonus
in voller höhe erhalten das ist zunächst
mal hier in dieser schwierigen zeit und
gutes signal für die familien
es gibt aber auch die kritik daran zu
recht dass es nicht nachhaltig ist eine
einmalige zahlung geben in einer zeit in
der die korona krise viele familien auch
finanziell wohl noch länger belastet
und das virus breitet sich in vielen
ländern weiter rasant aus indien hat
jetzt nach den usa die zweitmeisten
bestätigten fälle nämlich 4,2 millionen
bei uns in deutschland sind die
gemeldeten neuinfektionen leicht
gestiegen im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage haben sich
täglich 1200 menschen mit dem virus
angesteckt gestern waren es noch 1170
die ausführlichen corona zahlen und
entwicklungen zum nachlesen gibt es in
der zdf- heute- app dort auch noch mal
alle informationen zum kinderbonus und
zu weiteren hilfen die familien
entlasten sollen so jetzt ein thema das
jeden betrifft und das nicht nur im
supermarkt wie kann landwirtschaft
künftig funktionieren
ab heute will dass eine kommission
klären in der alle seiten zu wort kommen
die bauern selbst aber auch handel und
umweltschützer zuletzt hat sich da ja
einiges angestaut
die bauern klagen über die vielen
auflagen und den preisdruck dem sie sich
ausgesetzt sehen gleichzeitig belastet
intensiver landwirtschaft die natur vor
allem die böden und das grundwasser und
oft bleibt das tier wohl auf der strecke
weil manche betriebe sagen nur so
rentabel arbeiten zu können
oliver deuker rund 250 hektar acker
flächen bewirtschaftet volker hahn aus
neustadt bei hannover kartoffeln
getreide dazu hält der 1500 schweine
seine erwartungen an die kommission zur
zukunft der landwirtschaft sind groß wie
die probleme dieser branche wir erleben
den letzten jahren das ist eine
zunehmende polarisierung gibt das ist
also wirklich also extreme anforderungen
der gesellschaft gibt dass wir anders
rum der landwirtschaft gar nicht in der
lage sind gewisse dinge auch
durchzuführen weil sie an gesetzlichen
regelungen an rahmenbedingungen
scheitern und insofern glaube ich ist es
gut dass man miteinander redet und b
auch wirklich alle seiten bereit sein
müssen demgegenüber zuzuhören
friedrich bartels aus springe bei
hannover vor rund 25 jahren auf bio
landwirtschaft umgestellt die kommission
seine chance für alle seiten aber er hat
auch kritik sind natürlich viele
lobbyverbände jetzt hier drin wenn man
offen aufeinander zugeht kann das
ergebnis gut werden wenn man
traditionelle lobbyarbeit betreibt wird
das nichts bei raus kommen ökologie und
ökonomie in der konventionellen
landwirtschaft häufig ein widerspruch
das hauptproblem dabei der preisdruck
wir müssen es schaffen dass die
erwartungen die an die landwirtschaft
gestellt werden mehr klimaschutz mehr
umweltschutz mehr tierwohl dass es auch
leistbar ist von den familien und dass
es sich auch rechnet in ansonsten hätten
die betriebe auf in deutschland und wir
wollen das ist weiterhin betriebe gibt
in deutschland denn unsere landwirte
stehen im wettbewerb im globalen
kommenden juni will die 32 köpfige
kommission ihren bericht mit
empfehlungen vorliegen ein anfang ist
gemacht einfach wird es nicht
was jetzt kommt hat alles zeug zu einer
guten nachricht blinde wieder sehen
lassen es ist ein menschheitstraum an
dem der ungarische mediziner botond
roska arbeitet im labor funktioniert es
bereits inzwischen läuft auch die
klinische erprobung bei erblindeten
menschen für seine forschungen wurde ihm
heute der körper preis verliehen mit
einer million euro eine der
höchstdotierten wissenschaftlichen
auszeichnungen in deutschland christina
hansen hat die details dieser kleine
punkt ist ein baustein um womöglich
wieder licht in das leben blinder
menschen zu bringen
dem neurobiologen betont roska und
seinem team ist es gelungen aus
körperzellen von blinden patienten
künstliche netzhäute zu züchten die
meisten erblindungen gehen auf defekte
der netzhaut zurückgewiesen
wir können diese künstliche netzhaut
massenhaft herstellen und deshalb immer
wieder nach der ursache der erkrankung
suchen bis wir sie gefunden haben und
dann eine therapie ausprobieren die
wissenschaftler haben die einzelnen
gendefekte identifiziert hat man die
ursache der erblindung gefunden werden
lichtempfindliche zellen bausteine zum
beispiel aus algen in die echte netzhaut
des blinden gespritzt sie soll dann
wieder licht signale empfangen können
diese proteine haben hoch intelligente
dna bestandteile die selbstständig die
defekten gene finden und
deren arbeit übernehmen soll die
forschungsarbeit des ungarn gilt als
bahnbrechend mit dem körber-preis gibt
es nun eine million euro für weitere
forschungen der den körper preis bekommt
soll nicht nur zu den besten seiner
zunft gehören er oder sie soll auch von
dem unbändigen willen getrieben werden
ein gesellschaftliches problem zu lösen
oder eine menschliche misere zu lindern
mit sieben patienten läuft jetzt die
erste klinische studie in drei bis vier
jahren so schätzungen der
wissenschaftler können vielleicht schon
viel mehr menschen von den forschungen
profitieren jetzt noch was in eigener
sache es gibt neues im
nachrichtenangebot hier im zdf ab heute
hat das heute journal eine zweite
sendung am abend das heute-journal
update 15 minuten roto mitternacht mit
dem neuesten stand der dinge
und noch etwas ist neu zdf heute live
mehr live streams in der zdf- heute- app
und auf social media das alles zeigt uns
jetzt beach area noch viereinhalb
stunden dann gibt es zum ersten mal das
heute-journal update vertrauter lockt
neue und bekannte gesichter und ein
sendetermin gegen mitternacht
das heißt alles was nach dem journal
passiert das greifen wir hier bei uns in
der sendung auf uns passiert tatsächlich
eine menge in den usa zum beispiel nacht
sitzungen in brüssel oder auch mal ein
koalitionsgipfel der bis in die nacht
hinein reicht und das werden wir dann
alles hier abbilden
hanna zimmermann ist eine der beiden
haupt moderatorinnen die zweite ist nah
sein möchte mir den zuschauern unter
anderem bekannt aus dem täglichen arte
journal
ich habe schon das gefühl in große
fußstapfen zu treten möchte mich
allerdings nicht auf den lorbeeren
ausruhen
ich möchte dass das heute-journal update
eine eigene handschrift bekommt und vor
allem auch eine eigene informations
stärke entwickelt das heute journal
seit 42 jahren eine institution am
späten abend zum ersten mal in seiner
geschichte bekommt das magazin einen
zweiten sendeplatz und noch etwas neues
gibt es ab heute bei den zdf-nachrichten
zdf heute live stream bei großen
ereignissen und wichtigen entscheidungen
in der zdf- heute- app und auf social
media
dort können wir den direkten kontakt zu
den usern zuschauern halten und deren
feedback auch direkt mit aufnehmen also
das ist was sehr unmittelbares zdf heute
live und das heute-journal update die
zdf-nachrichten familie hat nochmal
zuwachs bekommen
ja klicken sie sich rein schalten sie
einen 23 45 heute abend ist hanna
zimmermann für sie da jetzt aber erstmal
christin und der sport von seinem
wutanfall mit folgen
angelique kerber ausgeschiedene
alexander zverev als einziger deutscher
tennis profi weiter dabei doch für
weitaus mehr schlagzeilen rund um die
achtelfinal-serie us open in new york
sorgt die disqualifikation von novak
djokovic
in seiner serbischen heimat titeln die
zeitungen von beispielloser
ungerechtigkeit bis kann da novak
djokovic und sein unrühmlicher abgang im
achtelfinale gegen den spanier karen o
bus dar
djokovic schlägt den ball wütend weg und
ohne absicht genau an die kehle einer
linienrichterin die nummer eins der welt
reagiert selbst bestürzt die
linienrichterin ringt nach luft ist zum
glück bald wieder wohlauf
ob absicht oder nicht der
oberschiedsrichter kennt keine gnade
die disqualifikation
gerecht djokovic verabschiedet sich
wortlos
später entschuldigt er sich in den
sozialen medien für sein verhalten
fakt bleibt der 2020 schier unbesiegbare
serbe hat sich in new york selbst
geschlagen
er werde noch ein bisschen brauchen bis
er diesen wurf verdaut hat so johannes
vetter nach seiner flugshow im
polnischen rzeszów bei der sein speer
fulminante 97,7 sechs meter weit schlug
die zweitbeste je mit einem neuen speer
geworfen weiter vetter übertraf seinen
deutschen rekord um mehr als drei meter
deutschlands fußballer warten weiter auf
den ersten sieg in der nations league
erneut nicht in bestbesetzung reichte es
auch in der schweiz nur zu einem 1 1 der
bundestrainer und die erkenntnis vieles
muss besser werden oder um es mit den
worten des torschützen zu sagen
insgesamt ist sehr sehr ärgerlich
es geht noch ein bisschen um den
einzigen deutschen treffer erzielte
gestern abend einer der besten auf dem
platz neben eco nur knapp 15 minuten
waren gespielt und doch nach einer guten
ersten halbzeit folgte ähnlich wie im
spiel gegen spanien eine mäßige zweite
die schweizer trumpften auf nutzten die
freiräume in der 58 minute widmer mit
dem ausgleich wenn man jetzt zweimal 1 0
führt und bringt es eigentlich dann
nicht nach hause das ist natürlich
ärgerlich auf jeden fall löst die wiese
für die oktober spiele lautet nun
angriff genau das am 17 oktober gegen
die türkei zunächst christin danke so
und jetzt eine heimkehr nach fast 90
jahren
die ppi ist zurück zu hause in hamburg
frisch restauriert 1911 lief der
viermaster dort vom stapel segelte 34
mal um kap horn ausgedient hat der fragt
segler aber noch lange nicht er soll
jetzt der neue star sein des deutschen
hafen museums so sagt man in hamburg
heute mal nicht süß sondern willkommen
zurück
aber wir in mainz sagen gleich zuerst
noch der hinweis aus zweigeteilte wetter
das steht morgen haben im süden sonne im
norden wolken alle details gleich von
westend elli und dann der hinweis auf
das heute schon mal mit der kollegin
bettina schausten um 21 45 und um 23 45
zum ersten mal das heute schon mal
update wir sagen bis morgen machen sie
sich ein angenehmer abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine
hochdruckbrücke hat sich etabliert und
zwar vom ostatlantik über frankreich bis
nach deutschland und diese
hochdruckbrücke sorgt für ruhiges wetter
nur ganz im norden deutschlands ziehen
mal dichtere wolken durch und es regnet
etwas zum beispiel in der kommenden
nacht richtung nordsee da wird es etwas
regnen der wind ist kräftiger aus
südwestlichen richtungen
sonst aber ruhiger und an der donau gibt
es nebel und die temperaturen sinken auf
8 bis 3 grad in der südhälfte 15 grad an
der nordsee morgen gibt es hauptsächlich
im norden sehr viele wolken die ostwärts
ziehen ja und etwas regen durch schauer
gibt es durchaus im nordwesten richtung
nordsee ansonsten südlich des mains
sonnenschein pur bei temperaturen bis 26
grad richtung main 25 am oberrhein und
19 grad zum beispiel im osten
deutschlands die nächsten tage am
mittwoch im norden weiterhin kompakte
wolken mit etwas regen kräftiger wind
aus südwest an der nordsee beim 19 bis
28 grad und ab donnerstag wird es
deutlich ruhiger und es bleibt weiterhin
war ein schöner abend